hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast just checking in on you how's
your week going huh did you having a
good one issue is your boss not touching
you in a way that doesn't make you feel
unsafe but it's still implied that
there's an unsafe 'no swiss aif T of the
safeness oh my god I gotta tell you
something I gotta get off the [ __ ] I
gotta stop reading [ __ ] on on on social
media jesus [ __ ] christ you know what
it is you just read your own [ __ ]
tweets what you don't want to do is you
don't want to click on the magnifying
glass and then just read the [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] that P uh and it's white why
does it sent me off you know a [ __ ]
looking through and then some [ __ ]
female comic just says hey headliners
gave us all a stern talking-to whether
you're innocent or not
don't [ __ ] gag again why'd you go
talk about your [ __ ] for another [ __ ]
hour on stage you [ __ ] hack jesus
[ __ ] christ my god for an hour a
[ __ ] hour to talk about whatever
figure she wants to blame your [ __ ]
alright yeah go ahead
don't say she's a dirty comic oh my god
and then movies come up why is Abraham
Lincoln still played by a white male why
is Hollywood so afraid to tell Abraham
Lincoln's story from a female
perspective new studies have shown he's
actually trans I mean there's like
literally that level of insane chatter
I don't know I you know I think I kind
of like to stick into Instagram where
it's just videos or you go to YouTube
because as bad as the Twitter experience
can be right I like and and that that's
the most [ __ ] first-world thing to
say ever you know is a bad experience
for me I know you're digging for blood
diamonds but my experience on Twitter
yesterday I think your experience pales
in comparison I don't care how many arms
you have left
I was watching Jeff Beck he's just the
[ __ ] best guitarist you see the best
guitarist ever then I was just I was
just seeing all the greats right from
then and now I just went down this
rabbit hole of just [ __ ] watching
these guys and I think it's Jeff Beck
Jeff Beck and then today maybe Derek
Trucks I'm sure there's a zillion others
which is why I'm saying this because
then I want you to write them to me
because I want to I want to listen to
but Jesus Christ
[ __ ] Jeff Beck I you know I got a
bunch of his albums and you know they're
all good I didn't know he did some sort
of techno stuff in the 90s I got to
check that out and see what that's all
about [ __ ] incredible player but I
had a great week other than [ __ ]
going on Twitter and listening to white
women complaining you know what's really
funny is when a white woman dyes her
hair blonde you know it's like you're a
white woman in the United States of
America you still weren't getting enough
you got to add a couple extra free
drinks every week you know
now you're gonna be happy where are all
the women in the movie where are the
people of color same way same place they
are in the women's March on [ __ ]
Washington they're extras it was all a
bunch of white broads up on [ __ ]
stage [ __ ] banging clams and
high-fiving each
about how [ __ ] you know progressive
they are alright I'm done okay
plowing ahead what I want to talk about
how about that [ __ ] Seattle Seahawk
San Francisco 49er game Monday night
game of the year game of the [ __ ]
year I was out with my buddy virzi it
was his birthday and he goes to 49 isn't
gonna kill him tonight and I said I said
I said Sneaky Pete the Seattle Seahawks
he's gonna shut him down he's gonna shut
those [ __ ] down and neither thing
happened but Seattle did win Seattle did
win but uh then I heard that 49ers had a
couple of their top wide receivers that
were out but just just to know that
they're gonna meet again and now the San
Francisco 49ers need to win the rest of
the way out okay and if they do that
then they get home-field and they get a
second crack it old sneaky Pete Carroll
it's just a [ __ ] great coach I was
calm sneaky pete because the way he ran
out the door at [ __ ] USC
but is it really his fault you know you
can't really blame Pete Carroll for USC
because if he didn't do it somebody else
would have done it because that is the
USC football program they're always
getting suspended they're always in the
middle of some some sort of something is
going on down there they can't help it
it's just it's just what they're doing
by the way speaking of that [ __ ] did
you see oh and let's keep talking about
Seattle Seahawks in the San Francisco
49ers I that level of football I have
not seen in the AFC this year if
somebody's seen it I want you to tell me
and I'm gonna look up the game and watch
it because that was just phenomenal
defense on both sides and the way the
quarterbacks responded the receivers
everybody the way everybody [ __ ]
played in that game and very little bit
of celebrating the biggest celebration I
saw was from a field goal kicker
I forget which side but he kicked he
kicked the ball through the uprights
anyway
field goal kickers celebrate now not
just you know the usual you know the
fist bump or whatever they do the 300
yell now I can see if you Adam Vinatieri
and you just kicked it through the
uprights to win yet another Super Bowl
yeah I get that you know game in
November in the [ __ ] third quarter
whatever bill you're an old man they're
young they celebrate everything and they
[ __ ] too with global warming coming
enjoy every second everybody anyway oh I
was talking about USC being on the you
know whatever some [ __ ] probation
after you know Pete ran out the back
[ __ ] door when I was in New York
there was some stupid [ __ ] about the
[ __ ] about the Houston Astros
stealing signs you know and there's
always gonna be a black mark this was
the guy they said in the New York papers
why cuz they beat your team is it gonna
always gonna be a black mark against all
those Yankee teams well you had to write
it up [ __ ] half you goddamn line up
you know no cuz that's our team but if
the Red Sox get busted for roids they'll
always be a black you know and then this
[ __ ] idiots going like they need to
get technology out of the game so they
could stop doing this it's like how are
you a sports writer and you don't know
you [ __ ] history didn't that game the
shot heard round the world weren't the
Giants all those years later admitted
that they had a guy with binoculars out
in center field stealing sides wait a
minute let me let me [ __ ] look that
up let me actually do a little bit of
research here shot heard round the world
baseball stealing signs in the suing
years rumors began to circulate that
during the second half of the 1951
season the Giants engaged in systematic
stealing of signs the final the finger
signals transmitted from a catch
the picture of the determine the pitch
thrown every hitter knew what was coming
said pitcher al Gettle and your first
question should be who the [ __ ] is al
Gettle well let's look him up
did he play on the other team is this
some Indianapolis Colts horseshit was a
major league baseball player in 1945
fifty-five several teams but what teams
did he play for Jesus he's got a quick
one he played for the New York Giants
1951 then he played for st. Louis in 55
well what the [ __ ] would this guy know
wait was 51 was that the shot heard
around the world shot heard round the
world was in 1951 all right when your
own players saying it there you go I me
if you're gonna take the Astros down and
they they all [ __ ] do it
everybody's doing a little something you
know what I mean
and I like all the unethical you know
sit there and say that they're cheating
you know they're literally write an
article sports right I'll write an
article about cheating and just over his
shoulders a little [ __ ] vial of
[ __ ] viagra you know like his dick
should be banned from the league no he's
not cheating is he he has a condition I
did I have EDM or the [ __ ] is called
erectile dysfunction AED is it just easy
Edie does your dick have ed anyway I got
to keep promoting this stuff I'll be at
the Mahalia Jackson theater Performing
Arts Center in New Orleans January 9th
and 10th the pre-sale ends this today
Thursday the code is burp bu are are the
public on sale is tomorrow Friday
November 15th 10 a.m. Central Standard
Time the link will be shared on all my
social or go to ticket and search BIR bu
are are all right Sonia I'm back out
here in LA you know out here to get some
sunshine and some Botox that's how we do
it out here so we all look so good you
know I don't know if you guys know this
but I [ __ ] I actually went to Tahiti
and had some of their tree bark rubbed
into the top of my
and the hair is starting to come back
you know and they had to decide between
me and a child being on life support and
they chose me because I had more money
and that's just how it works that's how
it works around the world speaking of
that I'm hearing a lot of chatter about
about Trump right now is he on trial is
that actually going down that big waste
of [ __ ] money to try and try and
impeach him I don't know what Democrats
are getting so [ __ ] excited about
about getting that guy out you need you
need like 3/4 of the vote which would
mean half of his party has to [ __ ]
turn on him which they're not gonna do
they're not gonna do and you know why
huh you know why because of all you
liberal [ __ ] morons well I can't just
blame them it's also the all the
[ __ ] on social media have driven
both parties so far away from each other
I don't give a [ __ ] what somebody with
the blue or a red tie does
no one's gonna vote against them if
they're wearing the same color tie you
go back [ __ ] 50 years ago
you know they got three-quarters oh wait
did he get impeached no he stepped down
he resigned huh there goes that [ __ ]
theory I don't know who the [ __ ] why
would you be watching that [ __ ] like
like like something's gonna happen like
he's actually gonna who wants to put a
bet on that about whether or not that
guy gets impeached or not there's
there's no [ __ ] way that guy gets
impeached I think at this point you know
Jesus Christ what I should show that guy
is you know there's a bunch of countries
over here and there's some other
countries too that the country's at but
level it's like you even if he sounds
like me doing my podcast Jesus [ __ ] how
about it can somebody prep the guy who
is running for president now I did see
that that that woman walked off when she
was asked a question I didn't think she
was being that rude
I thought the other person was implying
that she was racist and she got offended
and that's why she walked off it all
depends on who reads you know who you
read all right here we go who
who is running for president president
president who is running for president
in 2020
now this is coming from the New York
Times nice unbiased paper they're all
biased all right
Jesus Christ where did all these women
come from get back in the [ __ ] catch
I'm sorry let's see here it's a guy
named Bennett fightin Booker a lot of
bees Bullock button gig Castro I thought
he died Delaney or Delanie Gabby gab art
every Harris Club Walker massage Patrick
Bernie Sanders Sestak Strayer oh this is
[ __ ] this is like the first week of
the season
Warren Williamson yang Trump Walsh weld
Oh bill weld the old Massachusetts guy I
might vote for him
fellow freckled-faced son of a [ __ ]
dropped out nine Democrats and one
Republican I gotta tell you you know
there's a lot not running Hillary
Clinton okay there's a lot of broads
running for president I think that is a
good thing because I am progressive
let's see we got one two three four five
that's a pretty decent mix of people
there huh
you catch white guys you get your black
guys you got an Asian guy you got some
women you got an old guy you got bald
guys people part the hair on the left
and the right some women with the long
hair still looking sexy some women like
you know I've hit menopause haircut you
got hair plugs or whatever the [ __ ] is
on Trump's head bill weld you know the
old redheaded hair
you know we start to look like a
scarecrow Dark Knight II the Scarecrow
is running for [ __ ] president all
right this is just a [ __ ] show of a
podcast I don't know what I'm talking
about Ford versus Ferraris coming up
this weekend I'm so far behind I move
movies I gotta go see the [ __ ] joke
I gotta see kill the Irishman I have to
see what is that cold because with a pee
and it's not a good word it's not
pneumonia parasite
I guess see parasite and I got a C Ford
verse Ferrari and I think I got to do it
in that order but Ford versus Ferrari is
gonna be in like [ __ ] IMAX you know I
want to feel I'm underneath the car when
I go see I just want to go see that [ __ ]
you know that's an incredible story even
though I know this story I gotta see how
Hollywood tells the story hey headliners
how funny is that hey all of you um
anyway alright let's let's plow hit so I
was on the airplane right and I get on
the plane and it was a [ __ ] wide-body
right I don't mind a chick with a little
bit of girth right so I get on this
wide-body and I'm [ __ ] psyched you
never get to fly in those things and I'm
so excited I I got to my row and I sat
in the wrong seat and there was this
really nice woman she goes hey I don't
want to start anything but by said oh
sorry go on the other side you could now
you already got your stuff so you're
fine right so the flight already starts
great right it's a wide-body the the
people everybody's in a good mood we're
all gonna be flying in this giant living
room this is awesome so I started
watching I started watching some movies
and the [ __ ] that
watch I watched a documentary on this
guy who Carmine's guitars in New York I
watched American Graffiti which I hadn't
seen him forever
still [ __ ] funny as hell I still
think the biggest laugh is right in the
beginning when that kid comes on in the
motor scooter just [ __ ] if that if
that whole thing was on purpose that was
like one of the Great's slapstick
[ __ ] prop gags ever just a great
movie just a great movie the way they
deal the whole thing if you're trying to
learn how to write a script I think
that's a good one to watch as far as I
feel good it all comes together in the
end type of thing and then I actually I
always put on the classics so the
classics were American Graffiti jaws was
another classic but I've seen that a
million times
and then a star is born with no two
[ __ ] her name the one all the gay
comics used to always imitate Judy
Garland right so I put that [ __ ]
movie on that movie was a hundred and
seventy one minutes long and when I tell
you Judy Garland sings for like a
hundred and twenty five minutes of it
and just full-out [ __ ] Wow
oh [ __ ] I had to like take the
headphones off it got to the point I was
like I was just laughing watching it
like I don't yeah it sounds like an
incredible story it's about a guy who
[ __ ] you know he's a star he sees
this woman right he doesn't try to bang
her he tries to make her as he's a
progressive guy he tries to make her a
star right she becomes a star and then
she ends up becoming bigger than him and
then he can't [ __ ] handle it is
essentially the [ __ ] story right
although he does marry her and then he
starts banging it right so he's sort of
a lazy like toxic guy I guess I don't I
don't I don't know how to do the math
anymore I'll have to go on Twitter hey
movie stars
okay um anyway where else am I here what
am I talking about yeah dude like I'm
telling like she was singing like
back-to-back songs I mean that [ __ ]
movie if you took out her singing which
she really only needed to do a couple of
times before you alright I get it she
can sing can we get to this interesting
dynamic between the two of them that you
have this person who's reaching down to
help this other person and in Elvis and
the person he's helps out is gonna
[ __ ] then go on and pass him and I
want to see how this person handles it I
want to see that every five second
there's so much [ __ ] like if there
was ever a drinking game that every time
Judy Garland is singing you have to
drink you you'd have cirrhosis of the
[ __ ] liver by the time you got
halfway through that [ __ ] movie I got
I'm gonna do it right now I don't like
doing this to freckled thumbs down and I
was on a plane when I watched that to
Jesus [ __ ] Christ Judi well it's
probably wasn't her fault she's probably
I'm [ __ ] singing again in the scene
I'm we beating a dead oh the whole
[ __ ] movie
you know people did not have sing back
then right they just you got loud and
you puts a little vibrato and you know
most people didn't have TVs at that
point so it's just it was just different
it was easy to stand out if it was one I
let me turn in the depression oh I think
it's a conspiracy right that's all
everybody was talking about then
somebody's like what is that person
doing could you please do that for a
hundred and seventy one minutes I don't
have a radio or a television did that
movie make any [ __ ] money I kind of
tell you something to like every [ __ ]
scene - there was like nine thousand
extras and all this [ __ ] going on they
literally started off with an award show
and they shot an actual award show
te Fattah cuz I've been doing this thing
lately way I like watching the old
movies I don't know why I just like
watching them and then like especially
if they like remakes to see how they're
doing and when I saw that that was on
there I was like oh wow they've redone
this thing three times turns out it was
four times that was the second time
they've made that movie so I was like
you know what I'm gonna watch this one
then I'll watch the Barbra Streisand
Kris Kristofferson one and then I'll
watch the Lady Gaga in this sniper guy
right I'll [ __ ] watch that one and
just see how they changed it throughout
the years oh wow she's still singing but
she has a cell phone now right I won't
know why I was gonna [ __ ] it that's how
my brain works no I saw this now I have
to go [ __ ] and see all of them and the
plane landed before the goddamn thing
was done and at that point I literally
had the headphones on one ear and off of
the other I had to get my ears a break
with all of that [ __ ] singing it's
like for the love of Christ can you just
get to the point where her movie does
better than his movie or her singing
thing does better than him you know is
it just gonna be he becomes a dick are
they gonna show does she gonna change
when they divorce does she [ __ ] sing
a song to him I have to look this up to
see if anybody else is annoying but
annoyed by the amount of singing I mean
I is that considered a musical I don't
even know what I thought a musical like
the whole [ __ ] thing was basically
music and there's a little bit of dumb
maybe that's what it was maybe was a
musical wait is almost said is Lady Gaga
musical is is what the [ __ ] that I just
say the name of the movie was is a star
is born a musical or a drama
alright a star is born
is a 2018 American musical romantic
American musical romantic drama all
right let's see the Judy Garland is a
star is born is Judy Garland judy judy
garland she sang more in that movie than
Robert Plant saying unlike the [ __ ]
75 tour with Zeppelin his Julie Garland
all right a star is born is a 1954
American musical film well Jesus Christ
ethically it's not a musical it's a it's
a singing film I didn't hear a lot of
music I just heard her [ __ ] God the
whole [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] movie I
wonder if I was saying that out loud
shot come on it's the 1950s you can
shake it out of her come on get all
yourself get it a stop [ __ ] singing no
I'll watch the rest of him I know this
is sacrilegious to sit here and make fun
of that movie but allegedly it was about
you know a couple of Hollywood
relationships dish dish one of them
being Frank Fay and it was at Barbara
Stanwyck Frank fate Jesus Christ if you
want to read a [ __ ] Wikipedia page
that you never want to have listen to
this [ __ ] I [ __ ] look this up and I
was [ __ ] crying laughing go and look
this guy has to have alright this guy
has to have one of the worst Wikipedia
pages for someone who wasn't a dictator
this this was a stand-up comedian
actually arguably the first stand-up
comedian depending on who you believe
all right let's see here okay Francis
Anthony Donner aka Frank Fay
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah although very talented Fay offended
most of the people he worked with
because of his enormous ego this is on
his page former vaudevillian and radio
star
Fred Allen remarked the last time I saw
him walking down Lovers Lane wait
the last time I saw him he was walking
down Lovers Lane holding his own hand
Robert Wagner wrote fate was one of the
most dreadful men in the history of show
business
why haven't they made a movie about this
guy Faye was a drunk an anti-semite and
a wife beater
that's the Triple Crown of like [ __ ]
[ __ ] and Barbara Stanwyck had to
endure all of that well what the how did
it become about her while according to
actor and comedian
Milton Berle of Berle that guy Jesus
Christ ever since George Byrne trashed
him for stealing jokes I was just like
all right whatever you got to take
everything he says with a grain of salt
but that is literally on his [ __ ]
fate was a drunk an anti-semite and a
wife beater Jesus Christ how many times
would that guy get canceled today my god
and usually it's just like you hear
these things about this person or that
person well this is literally this is
the second paragraph of his obvious is
this of his a Wikipedia page and then
you look at a picture him he just looks
like some guy hey how are ya 23 skidoo I
remember reading in that history of
stand-up book that the guy [ __ ] he
was actually and this was a thing too
cuz they they never show this in movies
that there was like a it was a minority
but it was a large minority or Saturn I
don't you know what I shouldn't even say
that there was a lot of people that were
Pro fascism that lived in America during
World War two I didn't know that okay I
don't know a lot of things okay so one
night they want to have a rally after
the [ __ ] war ended they wanted to
have a [ __ ] rally
I believe it was after the war handed
the fascist and they needed a big name
to get to sell tickets they had it at
the original Madison Square Garden I
believe I'm just saying this from
[ __ ] my bad memory so they had a
night called the Friends of Frank Fay
let me look this up here they had the
Friends of Frank Fay in this [ __ ]
idiot went down and he hosted the thing
and you know that was that there goes
that career when you host the hey I
don't think Hillary was that bad gala
that tends to affect your [ __ ] career
here Friends of Frank Fay let's see what
it says here can't believe I got down
this [ __ ] friends are frankly the page
friends of Frank Fay does not exist well
you know what thanks a lot Wikipedia you
got you got everything else and here
Friends of Frank Fay here we go in
January 1946 an event called the Friends
of Frank Fay members of the Ku Klux Klan
and the American Nazi Party employed
speakers to talk about the Jewish
influence of America's communist
President Franklin D Roosevelt this
jackasses agent called them up and go
listen I'm sure this is a pass but you
know you told me to bring every every
offer to the table this January the 12th
year open the Ku Klux Klan and the
American Nazi Party
they're holding a think about the Jewish
influence of America's communist
President Franklin D Roosevelt would you
like to come down there and be the face
of that how much it apparently
Oh God why would you do that Jesus
Christ already did a [ __ ] half are
you alright anyway let me read let me
read a little bit advertising here
alright Oh max Oh max oh ma X that's the
name of a like a [ __ ] late sixties
one camera shoot Oh max oh wait it was
the [ __ ] was it called 99 in max what
was the name of that [ __ ] show I used
to watch it all the time
they made a movie of it starring Steve
Carell I'm the worst
alright Oh max problem whether you're an
athlete weekend or someone who deals
with constant joint pain back pain
muscle soreness or arthritis finding a
natural natural remedy that instantly
works might seem non-existent most
over-the-counter pain relievers such as
icy hot and bengay only focus on one
basic cooling effect such as menthol
which temporarily takes your mind off
the pain until the pain returns in an
hour or so solution unless you have
unlimited supplies of menthol you need a
solution solution if you're looking to
get rid of nagging muscle and joint pain
immediately while providing long lasting
recovery then you need to try the
natural breakthrough pain relief
solution cryofreeze CBB developed by Oh
Matt Oh max health this non-prescription
triple action pain relief roll-on is
specially formulated to block pain
receptors reduce inflammation and
improve muscle and joint flexibility the
best part is this is a hundred percent
natural CBD powdered remedy works its
magic within 10 minutes of application
and relief lasts up to eight hours much
longer than Julie I guess probably a
little bit less than Judy Garland sings
in a star is born' much longer than
over-the-counter products it's easy to
throw in your gym bag and take on the go
for
the emergency pain relief simply roll it
over wherever it hurts and ice out the
pain with an arctic blast Oh max health
is offering my listeners 20% off a full
bottle of cryofreeze pain relief roll-on
plus free shipping the disc this
discount also applies towards any
product site-wide just go - Oh max
health calm today and enter promo code
BRR - take advantage of this incredible
savings or answer the code bar that's o
m ax health calm and enter the code bird
to get 20% off cryofreeze and site-wide
alright lastly but not leastly simply
safe according to the FBI and the
average loss in a burglary is over two
grand
but even so only one in five homes have
home security you know what I'm
wondering that the criminals take TVs
anymore they used to be so small right
you could just sort of pick them all no
they were they were big and wouldn't
just trying to picture somebody running
out with a flat-screen under their
[ __ ] arm most companies really don't
make it easy
but simply safe wait but even so only
one in five homes have home security
despite the fact the average loss of a
burglary is too grand
according to the FBI most companies
really don't make it easy but simply
safe is different simply say protects
your whole home every window room indoor
with 24/7 monitoring for just a fraction
of the cost their police dispatch is up
to three and a half times faster than
with other companies because simply safe
uses video verification there's no
contract no hidden fees or fine print
this system is designed to blend right
into your home no why is no drilling
it's easy to order and easy to set up
usually in under an hour
simply safe has won a ton of awards from
C net to the New York Times wire cutter
prices are always fair and honest
around-the-clock monitoring it's just
$15 a month visits simply safe bird calm
you'll get free shipping and a 60 day
risk-free trial be sure to go to simply
safe bird comm so they know our show
sent you that simply safe bird comm okay
here we go you know something I didn't
you know cuz i interviewed Jessica
Kirsten thank you guys for all the kind
words about the interview I'd love to
have an Iran and her special talking to
myself
debuts on Comedy Central December 6th so
sit down and watch it with the friend
have yourself a sarsaparilla alright
okay here's some questions that he
didn't read the other day all right
western Pennsylvania isn't that bad dear
Bill Baldy you know if you want me to
hear your opinions you probably
shouldn't insulting me right out of the
gate
all right western Pennsylvania is not
that bad I live about 60 miles north of
Pittsburgh right where you said it's the
worst it was my worst experience now
listen not all of us up here are
chugging big dopes and banging out our
sisters some of us are shooting up and
getting hopped up off of opioids oh
brother okay well I guess you're right
this place is a bit of a dump but what
the hell I didn't think it was a dump
there was just something weird going on
anyways land is cheap and it's not and
it's not California
then again the municipal water supply is
downstream of the old washing
Westinghouse plant that is leeching PCBs
in the river so if he ever through here
don't eat the fish hugs and kisses and
go [ __ ] yourself you know I love how
that person disagreed and then agreed
with me all right dumbest state why did
I start this oh I would say you know
what's a New Yorker a native New Yorker
might be the dumbest person that's up
there they are some [ __ ] meatheads
and the thing about it is is because
everybody's written songs and told them
how great their city is they don't feel
that they need to travel so they're not
well it's the weirdest thing ever
they're in this incredible multicultural
metropolis but they haven't traveled so
they're like these townies like their
idea of traveling is taking the subway
from Brooklyn to Manhattan you know and
then when they go to other cities the
way they judge it is they count
buildings
I always have this argument with virzi
and Yanis pampas you know they're only
leg go to San Antonio I mean look at
this that's a skyline like they're
architects they think they even design a
[ __ ] tree fort look at all our
buildings this is the one thing of those
is amazing about New York and I do love
New York but what is something that they
don't mention about New York is that
probably well it's just a random numbers
out here I would if 65% of the people in
New York live above the poverty line 98%
are earning above the poverty line like
I would say at least eighty eight
percent of them live below the poverty
line some of the worst living you will
ever do is your apartment in New York
City I mean I've gone to cities in like
where people store their extra [ __ ] is
bigger than some people's [ __ ]
two-bedroom apartments in New York and
then you play like eight grand a [ __ ]
month or something crazy all right
dumbest eight
hey there bill Thai drummer boy first
off I'd like to say how much I
appreciate you having these part okay
thank you very much sorry my name I'm
not gonna say your name pronounced I'm
not gonna say any of this [ __ ]
I am an Iowan born and raised living in
upstate New York I'm currently in grad
school and have four jobs yes I'm a hard
worker the first part of my ordeal is
about New York taxes then I'll talk
about the dumb at the dumb ass State
all right dumbest taxes New York has the
dumbest taxes oh you should come to [ __ ]
in California as an Iowan who currently
is in grad school in Rochester New York
City hometown of steep yet I've been
burdened with the taxes I've had to pay
because New York because of New York
City which I am five hours away from all
there was also a lot of people that
trashed on
Trump in New York and also in California
from what I've heard he went out of his
way to extra taxes so you got that going
onto one example recently New York has
raised the age for purchasing tobacco
products to 21 in in turn raising the
taxes on those products if you think
about it from a theory
theoretical perspective this means that
they are yet again taxing the poor who
buy cigarettes
everybody I thought I didn't know rich
people didn't buy cigarettes from oh I
guess maybe they send their help down to
get them anyway from the center of
Disease Control and Prevention oh I
guess this is gonna say that what
smoking is a young person thing current
cigarette smoking among adults in the
United States cigarette smoking is the
leading cause of preventable disease the
United States accounting for more than
four hundred eighty thousand deaths
every year well that's great
it's too many people thank god the
cigarette companies are still out there
killing people by gender men were more
likely to current to be current
cigarette smokers than women nearly
sixteen of every 100 adults smoke
cigarettes that's pretty low though
about twelve of every 100 adult women
that's pretty low that's good I think
when I was a kid I want bet the height
was like thirty to forty percent
current cigarette smokers was higher
among persons ages 18 to 24 25 to 44 and
45 to 64 years then among those aged 65
and older doctor told him to stop or
they're gonna die about 10 of or you
died by the timing before you get to 65
all right [ __ ] this study all right here
we go but by annual income current
cigarette smoking was higher among
persons with a low annual household
income than those with higher annual
household income about 21 of every 100
adults with an annual household income
of less than I don't give a [ __ ]
alright dumbest people Florida has to be
the dumbest people if you're
remember that goddamn trend Florida man
you will understand where I'm coming
from basically the trend consisted of
people looking up Florida man and their
birthday and you will find some crazy
article about some dumbass doing
something in Florida that got him
arrested in defense of Florida there's a
lot of transplant people so there might
be a lot of dumbasses moving to Florida
just like a lot of phony [ __ ]
jerk-offs move out to [ __ ] in California
like myself so I don't know about that
one
I still think I'm winning cuz nobody
[ __ ] moves to West Virginia I mean
sorry western Pennsylvania
my birthday is October 18th I know what
you're thinking it's okay that you
forgot to wish me a happy birthday I'll
let it slide my Florida man article
Florida man shot outside bar after
rejecting shot inside bar Florida man
accused of cutting off penis of ex ex's
new boyfriend Florida man tells deputies
cocaine on his nose is not his Florida
man accused of assaulting roommate with
a slice of pizza oh that's on my tall
those last two were from my birthday
isn't that nice okay I feel like this is
evidence enough straight-up fact and
because you like straight-up answers
just like myself here are the straight
the state's ranked by IQ oh no you found
this study this is gonna end this whole
[ __ ] fun thing here well you know
have to agree with the study right let's
see here
all right 50 stakes stakes 50 states
ranked by intelligent scores all right
okay all right intelligence by state
ranked from the most to the least the
smartest state Massachusetts that's not
true that's cuz of all those [ __ ]
Smarties that [ __ ] go to MIT in
Harvard I would think there's a lot of
great colleges there maybe the people
fall in love with the city and they
stick around I don't know it certain
wasn't me and all my knucklehead friends
number two men
soda number 3 New Hampshire number 4
connecticut look at that new england
crushing it three of the top four
[ __ ] slots number five wisconsin the
midwest coming strong minnesota
wisconsin and there's kansas at number
six it's all tied up vermont at seven
new england is pulled ahead iowa it's
tied four to four new jersey high how do
you like that wait is this going dumbest
the smartest let me make sure here o
from most to least alright i am right ok
new jersey number 9 and then colorado
finally the first one in mountain time
south dakota nebraska 13 virginia 14
north dakota Illinois Missouri number 17
New York that's ranked 17th Ohio Maine
Maryland Michigan all right it's
Michigan's the first one outside the top
20 all right here we go it's going
downhill people in Ohio must be excited
that you are three states smarter than
Michigan
alright 22 on down Montana Washington
Utah Wyoming Pennsylvania 26 Rhode
Island alright we only got one or so
Maine is the dumbest [ __ ] New England
state 28 Oregon Delaware Oklahoma all
right oh Jesus you know when I noticed
there hasn't been a lot of things down
south huh those [ __ ] after the
Civil War they they didn't get the good
books
alright 31 Kentucky 32 Indiana Tennessee
California Idaho Arkansas Alaska Jesus
when you live above the [ __ ] Arctic
Circle what do you think is gonna happen
give a [ __ ] you just try not to freeze
to death you don't have time to read how
to fight off a grizzly
bear outside my captain page one all
right 38 Georgia 39 Texas you know 40
New Mexico you talking about Walter
White live there that guy was a genius
41 Arizona 42 North Carolina 43
Louisiana 44 West Virginia 45 South
Carolina 46 Florida 47 Alabama 48
Mississippi 49 Nevada 50 Hawaii I never
saw that one coming Jesus Christ who I
never would have guessed Hawaii last I
would have guessed I would have guessed
Mississippi just as far as the ones that
get bad publicity I would have guessed
Mississippi I woulda guessed West
Virginia and I would have guessed
Pennsylvania just because it's so
[ __ ] big and it only has like two
real cities in it Pittsburgh and Philly
you know nobody goes to Harrisburg right
you know I didn't realize Gettysburg all
those years to Gettysburg Address I
always thought that was down south I
didn't realize that that was in
Pennsylvania you know what if I'm ever
made a state I'm gonna be 51st on that
[ __ ] list all right let's get on to
the next thing here all right acetate to
blame Massachusetts the smartest state
out there I love it
acetate to blame I gotta send that to
Yanis Pappas hey Bill back and back in
my day birth you'll do it someday buddy
you will do it someday saw this article
and thought of you
not sure what your thoughts are on
vaping I don't vape but know that you
are that there are pros and cons to it
it looks like acetate might be to blame
for some of the negative side effects a
lady who's been listening to your
podcast for years I appreciate all your
viewpoints and honestly also love the
special me and my sister watched it
together and laughed the whole way
through take care thank you alright
let's see the whole thing on vaping and
acetate
acetate acetate alright break through
and CDC vaping illness investigation
well I mean you're you're bringing
[ __ ] [ __ ] into your lungs it's not
good I mean I don't understand why this
was it's not as bad as cigarettes that
kill four hundred eighty thousand people
a year in a Merck vitamin E acetate and
additives sometimes used in THC and
other vaping products may be to blame
for a national outbreak of e-cigarette
related lung injuries that linked to
dozens of deaths according to US Centers
for Disease Control and Prevention
officials dr. Anne shoosh at what a
great name shoot chat dr. Anne Schuchat
she loved that guy unless she's not
married the principal deputy director of
the CDC said she would characterize it
as a breakthrough in the mmm patting
yourself on the back these new findings
are significant once I heard popcorn
lung I was like I will never [ __ ] do
that again
alright hair problems oh come on people
have a little bit of [ __ ] sympathy
huh
alright hair problems hey Billy ball bag
breath let's see here first first things
first love the podcast can't wait for AF
f is for family season for come to a
show and Winnipeg Canada you lovable
[ __ ] I haven't been there in a minute I
had a great time when I was up there I
would definitely I should I should come
back I played a great old theater about
six years ago I started to notice that
my hair start I know started to notice
my hair start to get thinner and my
hairline creeping back at the time I
never really thought anything of it but
I'm not the most attractive guy in the
world and I don't think this is helping
my case I've had quite a few first dates
but never a second and I know if well
maybe you have [ __ ] ball bag breath
stop blaming your hairline and I know
for a fact that in today's [ __ ] up
society looks are everything this is
really starting to [ __ ] with my
self-esteem I'm only 22 years old and
I'm still not at the point of accepted
my Barbara mentioned the option of a
hair transplant but that scares the crap
out of me
I don't want this thing towering over me
for the rest of my young life as someone
who has experienced hair loss have you
ever had to deal with poor self-image
over your life now oh no not at all any
input would be much appreciated thanks -
go [ __ ] yourself um yeah absolutely I
did absolutely I felt like a freak when
I was growing up had [ __ ] orange hair
I used to literally think in my I used
to think you know I'd have a girlfriend
if I didn't have [ __ ] orange hair I
would literally think [ __ ] like that
rather than just going up and making him
laugh and asking him out I would have
been fine I had all I had all kinds of
[ __ ] issues you know skin the colour
of wall paste with you know [ __ ]
freckles I was a freak still am but what
I have found is what works the best is
to you just steer into it you don't mean
no matter what the [ __ ] you do this dish
there's only one Brad Pitt you're not
gonna be Brad Pitt so like I just keep
yourself in shape you know
self-deprecating humor is great make fun
of yourself who gives a [ __ ] I don't
know I found that like that actually
accepting what you look like is a real
confident move and women are attracted
to confidence and you'll do fine
alright it's probably not a good thing
to continue to go on [ __ ] Instagram
and look at all these people who are
taking holding the camera over their
heads so they try to look better-looking
than they really are
you're fine you know you want you want
somebody to marry you because you have
hair in your head you know the second
eye I didn't love you at first but the
second I saw your hair coming back I
decided I would love to have half of
what you have that's not a good way to
find a wife my friend I mean I with
empathy it's got to be tough to be going
through that at 22
but yeah I would just [ __ ] go to the
gym joke about it I I don't I don't know
I I don't know but who knows you know
but if you're gonna do the hair
transplant thing I I really believe the
longer you can hold out the better
because they just keep getting let him
practice on a more heads until they get
it down but they got it down pretty good
you know I don't know they have these
things you can take and it's supposed to
stop the hair loss I don't [ __ ] know
but I always think you can't get you
cake and eat it they always has to be
some [ __ ] side effect or whatever the
hell it is you're taking but I would
just yeah if you're gonna ride it out I
wouldn't try and hide it you just cut it
down shorten and then that's [ __ ] it
who gives a [ __ ] and be a cool guy be a
nice guy be empathetic be a warm
wonderful person that people are happy
that shows up and without a doubt you
will meet somebody all right but you
know you're gonna get your teeth [ __ ]
whitened or capped and get hair plugs
and [ __ ] you will also meet somebody and
she's gonna look like a strap all right
girlfriend wearing infinity ring which I
know who doesn't want to bang a stripper
yeah but you'd want to marry one right I
know is there any strippers listening I
probably shouldn't say that what the
[ __ ] do I know about strippers all right
girlfriend wearing infinity ring I don't
know what an infinity ring is I know
it's a car hey Oh Billy bounty hunter oh
yeah that's right Star Wars came out on
Tuesday so many people subscribed that
Disney Plus crashed
I hope it's up and running and I also
like that there you know you know they
got all those other shows on that so if
I don't know what else they got on there
just go on for the Star Wars that's what
you're signing up for wondering if you
can weigh in on something for me first
a little context my girl and I have been
together for a year now and things are
going well I'm happy with her and in
love and the feelings are mutual
according to what she says and what I
feel from her the other night we went to
dinner I this is the way that you wrote
that I'm a little concerned about the
rest of this [ __ ] email the
night we went to dinner with her whole
family to celebrate her niece's birthday
my girl doesn't wear Julie very often so
I noticed that she had a ring in
earrings on then I look closer at a ring
and I noticed that it was the infinity
symbol but at the time I didn't
overthink it too much all right I have
to tap out right now and I have to look
up what whatever the [ __ ] what is the
infinity symbol
what is this hang on a sec infinity
symbol meaning jewelry okay
oh yeah it's it's a it looks like a
pretzel the meaning behind jewelry with
an infinity symbol symbol is lovely it
symbolizes interna t empowerment and
internal love the infinity symbol has no
beginning and no ending it can mean
different things for example infinite
friendship love or spiritual bond okay
so she's wearing the C is an infinite
thing with somebody and you don't know
who the [ __ ] it is alright um later at
her place she took off her jewelry she
took her jewellery off and I asked her
where she got the ring because in the
back of my mind it seemed kind of
significant she vaguely said that she
got it a long time ago
oh boy today it's kind of bugging me I
think most people have a gift or two
from an ex laying around but it's the
symbol of infinity that is what I'm
stuck on my question to you is should I
question her again about whether the
ring was a gift from an ex or just let
it slide I don't think she's cheating on
me or is I don't think she's cheating on
me or is really stuck on an old
boyfriend okay
would asking her just stir things up of
course it will in an otherwise good
relationship you are the Dear Abby of
this generation but much funnier thanks
[ __ ] yourself um you know how I always
handle this type of [ __ ] I always I
always just never gave a [ __ ] it's like
look if you want to be hung up on this
other [ __ ] person and be a [ __ ]
jerk I don't give a [ __ ] I I would never
spend any [ __ ] energy on it you know
it might not be anything but if it does
mean something and some day she's gonna
break you [ __ ] heart you're already
in love with this so you're already
[ __ ] so [ __ ] her who gives a [ __ ] the
dumb [ __ ] jewelry that she you know
it's probably one of these things it
could just be this thing that you know
it was like the the [ __ ] you know
sitting down with the parents so she had
to break out some jewelry to try to look
[ __ ] a little bit nicer you know you
never know how women think this could be
like a subtle [ __ ] nod and she could
have that that she wants you to give her
some jewelry for [ __ ] Christmas and
she's pissed at you that you didn't take
the [ __ ] hint so I don't know but
she's just vaguely said that she got it
a long time ago I don't know that's
[ __ ] weird it is [ __ ] weird and I
can't this is this is the thing about
[ __ ] broads is if you [ __ ] showed
up wearing that [ __ ] you would have had
to [ __ ] deal with it probably during
dinner cuz she would already started
pouting then you have a big [ __ ]
thing and then she'd have to watch you
literally physically throw it out and
then you'd have to go out and go buy her
the same [ __ ] thing a little bit
bigger a little bit shinier and a little
you know more expensive and all of that
[ __ ] [ __ ] but as a man what you have
to realize is that women are not held
accountable for their [ __ ] actions in
a relationship they just are not so what
you got to [ __ ] do is you either got
a you know what I can't tell you what
Yui that the [ __ ] address this [ __ ]
or just say [ __ ] it personally I would
just say [ __ ] it alright well let's be
honest I would say [ __ ] it and then a
few months down the road we would get
into an argument then I'd bring it up
you know I just thought you were rude to
my friends yeah
and we said that wearing the jewelry
some guy use the [ __ ] parents dinner
where is that coming from they're like
three months ago
[Music]
yep who are you I don't know all right
girl cried girl cried after first date
oh Jesus
crying about what oh my god oh Jesus
shut off the waterworks there I hope she
was standing in the LA River all right
girl cried after the first date hey Bill
I'm a fan of puck all right right right
right right right right I was hoping you
could give some insight into this date I
took my friend on yesterday here's the
deal I'm an enlisted man from the whole
sub off we go over hill over Dale I
don't know last one all right
I'm an enlisted man and recently took my
friend to the marine corps ball wait how
we're not a four-fight sighs off we go
is the airforce from the halls of
Montezuma that's the Marines the army is
over a hill over there we will hit the
dusty trail what is the Navy song oh
that's right in the Navy you can sail
the seven seas Navy fight song row row
row your boat Anchors Away my boy all
right okay here's the deal I'm an
enlisted man and I recently took my
friend to the marine corps ball she was
really excited to go and went the whole
night she bought a new dress shoes
drooly and even went to go get her
makeup done the plan for the night was
to have a few drinks enjoyed dinner and
Dan
afterwards oh boy it sounds like the
first 48 he went to a party to meet a
friend he never got there we get we get
there and socialize a bit while having
cocktails and right now you're altering
your mental state gee what could happen
next
generally things seems to be seemed to
be going well the thing is that before
dinner started we went up to the hotel
and ended up having sex all right wait a
sec you took your friend you're not
saying girlfriend before dinner started
you went up to the whole troll and he
ended up having sex
alright so were you having like before
dinner cocktails and then you banged and
now you're gonna come downstairs and
help the lasagna and [ __ ] meat patty
or whatever they were serving anyway we
missed out on dinner and dancing and
instead turned in for the night while
she was taking a shower I could hear her
crying oh boy it wasn't until then that
I realized how much coming to this thing
meant to her I felt like a total dick Oh
God you went to the two-minute offense
in the second corner any advice on how
to go on how to go from here I really
care about this girl and making her cry
so legitimately one of the worst
feelings I've ever experienced well I
would tell her that oh yeah she also has
a boyfriend oh boy okay now pull the
ripcord sir and she's been cheating on
him for the past month with me we've
known each other for awhile and I'd like
to know what you think about the whole
thing thanks and go [ __ ] yourself I
think you both need to [ __ ] I think
you need to walk away that's what I
think I think she was crying I don't
what you guys sound like you young you
know you don't know how to [ __ ] you
know there's no class the whole time
when you're growing up they [ __ ] you
teach a geometry like you're gonna go
design a goddamn bridge someday which
most of us never do but all of us are
gonna have to break up with somebody at
some point they never tell you how to do
it so that's probably what the [ __ ]
she's going through
I don't know dude that's that's a that's
a you never start a relationship with
somebody who's cheating on somebody else
that's one of the oldest things in in
the book you know what I mean cuz
eventually they're gonna end up cheating
on you isn't that how that works isn't
that how they say that I would just tell
it that you know here when you cries one
of the worst feelings I've ever had I
don't I couldn't tell what you were
crying about big if it was because you
wanted to go to the that ball and we
tapped out halfway through or if you're
crying about your current complex social
life whatever you don't got it dance
around just wailing what are we doing
here have you are you already have a
boyfriend you need to break up with this
guy we can't continue seeing each other
like this I would suggest that you guys
break up take some time off from each
other and then figure out what the
[ __ ] going on cuz I don't know
you don't ever want to be with somebody
too who just got out of a relationship
and then immediately goes to you because
to me that just seems like they're
afraid to be single and then they're
gonna settle for you and then you're
gonna love them and they're just
settling for you and then one day
thinking they're gonna go to another
ball they ain't going with you right
alright that's it that's the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcasts have a great weekend
you [ __ ] once again congratulations to
the [ __ ] Seattle Seahawks man they
will look at strong I didn't know
Clowney was on their team they are gonna
be a [ __ ] problem and as a Patriots
fan I am glad that the 49ers in Seattle
will play each other hopefully and one's
gonna take the other one out who knows I
mean not saying that the Patriots will
make the Superbowl I'll tell you right
now that uh that Baltimore game was in
an addicting sort of education about
what's gonna be coming up here against
some of these more competitive teams
around the league I'll tell you the the
Patriot cut to work cut out for all
right go [ __ ] yourselves I'll see you on
Monday
eeee a how do I shut this off
I for one min a little sick of it awful
for this podcast sucks this podcast
sucks so far you know what it is because
I'm not really paying attention what I'm
doing I'm trying to adjust where I'm
gonna sit Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] just dropped
it there we go is that better well
listen you know what the good thing is
you know what's the great thing about
having a [ __ ] train wreck is as bad
as it is to listen to on some level it
has to make you guys feel better about
your lives doesn't it you know well [ __ ]
at least if I mean I don't do a podcast
but if I were to do it there would be
some sort of preparation all right I got
nothing but good news this week
everybody nothing but good not thing I
got nothing but good news this week all
right first things first for you cute
little Monday morning podcast ears I
went out and I figured out what the
[ __ ] problem was it was a simple
thing I just had a problem with Hawaii
and I went out and I bought I just went
to Kitaj Anna and I alleviated the
problem cuz I went out and I'm rather
than buying the little douchey $8 cord
you know like my parents just bought me
a ukulele for my 12th birthday and I
have a rock and roll dream you know so
then I go out and I buy the cheapest
[ __ ] to plug into an amp instead I went
out and said [ __ ] that give me the
hundred dollar one give me the one Jimmy
Page uses when he plays those guys music
and then doesn't give him credit for it
give me that one I want that one
so I got that one so now we're good all
right the levels should be fine
everything should be fine and if you
don't like it I suggest you pack up your
little [ __ ] iPod or whatever you
listen to this thing on and you just get
the [ __ ] out of my podcasting world what
do you think about that um very hostile
bill very hostile for someone who has
nothing to [ __ ] about yeah I don't I
have nothing to complain about I
basically just rapped the most
unbelievable [ __ ] month of my life
you know I don't think there's gonna be
any
how many on this one everybody I am
[ __ ] ecstatic alright I got a brand
new website everybody and of course I
went to go on it and I can't get on it
but it should be up by the time you
listen to this
or maybe it's my computer I don't know
what the [ __ ] going on I got one of
these laptops that's like I don't know
at this point it's almost three years
old which is basically it's basically
the laptop equivalent of like a 47 year
old strip you know it's it's still doing
the job it still looks alright you know
it still can do the little tricks can go
on the internet you can [ __ ] drop
down to a split and bring that booty
right back up again you know but it's
tired I can see it it's got a little
varicose veins on the side of the
plastic it's just it's it's had its time
and I feel bad for it never found love
it always said that it was only gonna be
a laptop for like you know a year year
and a half and then I was gonna go back
to school and become a [ __ ] iPad or
some [ __ ] but it didn't it's just become
a cliched laptop and what am I gonna do
with it you know I'd love to donate it
to a school but some of the porn I've
looked at I don't need that I don't need
to send that over to kids and then all
of a sudden it comes back to me I don't
need that so you know what I'm gonna do
with it I'm gonna throw it in the
[ __ ] trash it's gonna end up in that
cesspool of [ __ ] out there in the middle
of the ocean you know that's two miles
deep and twice the size of Texas and
some flounders gonna swim right through
it and you [ __ ] months later I'm
gonna be eating some sushi you know
thinking of being healthy what am i
doing I'm eating my old [ __ ] laptop
with a side of rollerblades a couple of
beanie babies with my Eddy mount edamame
that's what's out there in the ocean you
guys realize that it's all those [ __ ]
fads you forgot about remember those
razor scooters was the last time you saw
one of those where is it maybe that's in
your garage that'd be a good thing to
hold on to that was sort of made out of
a precious metal maybe that's something
you could melt down during some sort of
zombie
crisis and make a sword you know could
you get away from a zombie with a with
the scooter while you [ __ ] nerds out
there who are into that type of [ __ ] if
you had a little Razor scooter could you
do it what if you dropped your glasses
you [ __ ] sci-fi douche then what
would you do that would be hilarious
watching you squint down the street
you already know you're uncoordinated if
you're a nerd if you're into sci-fi
this is something this is one of the
choice statements never gonna make if
you're into sci-fi
you have no hand-eye coordination you
know that's why the football players
always threw [ __ ] at your head it's not
because they were [ __ ] it's because
they knew you didn't have the ability to
send them some sort of signal to your
[ __ ] hands to get him up in time or
eise at least get him in the right
position that's why they did it you know
why don't you step outside your little
bullying self bullied self I should say
and just realize that you know yes it
was your head yes it was your childhood
but as a man be honest is there anything
funnier than seeing somebody with a bad
haircut take some sort of object to the
side of the head at about 3035 miles an
hour
there's just nothing funnier than that
you know and a lot of ways
all these [ __ ] nerds who are getting
bullied it's their fault it's not even
their fault it's their parents fault
what are you doing you went to school
let's say you're a nerd right and you
went out you found some other nerdy
broad at some nerdy [ __ ] event right
and then you guys you [ __ ] went in
the Corning you I don't know what you
did you was so excited that another
human being liked you that you forgot to
put on a condom and next thing you know
nine months later you got yourself
another little nerd all right and you
love the little bastard he looks just
like came out of the womb wearing
glasses this is this is
[Music]
your seed alright have you been bullied
and you got the living [ __ ] kicked out
of you that's not something you ever
[ __ ] forget okay you don't ever
forget that you sit back here analyzing
you talk to a higher power why me why
why was I born this way why am I the guy
how come I can't catch anything in gym
class why am i required to still go the
[ __ ] dumb jock well you know why cuz
it dumb jock still has to go to science
class alright another problem another
question answered in my own [ __ ] head
alright so anyways you remember all
those beat downs and you have all those
[ __ ] fantasies about going in there
Jeremy spoke right doing something
[ __ ] crazy but you don't what do you
doing you say [ __ ] this I'm going out in
the [ __ ] world and my douchey little
nerdy card I'm gonna find other nerds
and we're gonna get together so we're
gonna start a computer company right and
then we'll sit in on the lotus position
hugging it because it's our friend
because it was never mean to us because
it could take us to faith and beyond I
really don't know I'm going with this
yes buckle up shut the [ __ ] up I where
am I
Oh going to space in the art and then
you became a success right then you went
to comic-con you finally got your dick
wet and now you got a [ __ ] nerd ass
kid so here's my question to you nerd
dad daddy nerd Big Daddy nerd nerd let
me get let me ask you a [ __ ] question
how do you forget to not send your kid
to school looking like a spaz how do you
how do you forget get up some contacts
comas [ __ ] hair just [ __ ] try to
see what the other kids are wearing and
put him in that uniform
give him the best [ __ ] chance he
possibly has to not get the [ __ ] kicked
out of him
that's the problem that's the problem
with these [ __ ] nerds they don't
learn anything from the childhood the
same way the [ __ ] football player
douche right he goes out and goes and
bangs some chick named Debbie who never
wore panties you know but she had
pom-poms so she's a good catch right he
goes on just drops a [ __ ] load right
in her nine months later right now they
got some little douche all right coming
out of the womb already looking like
he's wearing shoulder pads he's all
ready to start picking on some little
spaz you know same way the football
player doesn't learn anything why would
he learn anything he had a great [ __ ]
time you know as you were at home
jerking off to cheerleaders he was
actually [ __ ] him for all you know if
he gained enough yeah he might have
bagged what do you teach us it happens
it's all I'm saying it's all this talk
in the news about bullying okay it
shouldn't be done blah blah blah and all
this type of [ __ ] you know where is your
responsibility as a [ __ ] parent to
not send your kid to school to avoid
sending your kid to school with please
beat the [ __ ] out of me clothes you know
oh my god I remember one time I went to
school right I came from a big family
you know this is you know my mom did the
laundry but this is before the whole
[ __ ] I wash her and I dryer you can
just [ __ ] just rooty-toot-toot and
get the whole [ __ ] thing done in two
seconds back in the day you had to scrub
it down by the brook hang it by a tree
and then pack your muskets or some
[ __ ] Davy Crockett looking douche
wouldn't come by and steal it now we
didn't have a dryer so we used to hang
it between the trees but we had a washer
we had a washer so anyways I was running
out of [ __ ] clothes you know and I I
was down to the last I think I told the
story before right I was down to the
two [ __ ] things I had in my closet
one was a [ __ ] button-down shirt that
my grandmother got me it was like
[ __ ] somewhere between baby blue and
the [ __ ] and in West Hollywood that
was the color of it right it was
basically the Seinfeld puffy shirt
before Seinfeld it didn't have the
ruffles in the front but it just it was
really there was no reason to ever wear
this shirt unless you were onstage
playing the hero in some sort of pirate
movie put it that way all right
very very puffy sleeves pop I could have
fit his arm in there
no problem a lot of people don't know
that that's why Popeye didn't wear a
button-down shirts because he was a
sailor you know he was a pirate
he'd go to war look you could have all
those puffy ones and his forearms would
have fit maybe he was a pirate um
anyways so I was down in that step
[ __ ] ugly ass goddamn grandmother's
shirt and I swear to God all I had left
was this pair of they were pinkish
orange two-toned slacks I know that
sounds gay as hell but it was the 70s
there was two pairs of them one was was
light blue and then the other one was
this rusty orange but definitely pink
going on in him and they basically the
pants were dark this took the legs of
the pants were dark but the pockets on
the back what were dark blue the legs of
the pants were dark blue and the back
pockets were a lighter blue and I think
up around the waist there was another
design you know at the top of my [ __ ]
little eight-year-old booty crack was
another little light blue design I sort
of got it was it was it was designed by
a pedophile somewhere somewhere in
France where evidently it's legal
so anyways but that pair even that pair
was in the wash so I had the rusty
orange pinkest version of those pants
with this sky-blue [ __ ] pirate shirt
and I was sitting there
I was just old enough to realize that it
might have been a problem but just young
enough to be too stupid to fake sick and
not go to school so I said I don't know
about this I was looking at it and I was
like yeah I think I'm gonna be alright
[ __ ] right then I put on like a pair
of dirty like adidas Dragons or
something what the school and I know it
was in trouble second I got off the bus
and my friends were looking at me and
they were just looking me up and down
and they were trying to figure out what
the [ __ ] was going I'm trying to play it
off but I had my coat on at this point
so you can only see a little bit of my
shirt but you could definitely see these
head-to-toe big pants and they would
just go whoa I was in the fourth grade
what kid asked me if I had a date ah
long story short it was the longest
[ __ ] day of my life people who I
thought were my friends immediately
became people I never spoke to again for
at least another two weeks which is like
nine years when you're in fourth grade
it was one of the worst [ __ ] days I
have had my life alright and this is the
thing about the parents and nerds they
[ __ ] send their kids to school like
that every [ __ ] day how do you forget
let's say you don't know [ __ ] about
fashion just get him a [ __ ] pair
three four pairs of [ __ ] jeans some
sort of blue get him some black gray
some [ __ ] manly goddamn colors all
right and just tell him to keep his
[ __ ] mouth shut just go look don't
bring up that don't bring up that
[ __ ] Star Trek [ __ ] to the football
players keep your [ __ ] head down I
swear to God if any my fight is some
nerdy little kid that's what I would do
all right
and if if some [ __ ] kid ever kicked
the [ __ ] out of my kid I would
immediately I would send my nerd to a
goddamn CIA jujitsu Israeli [ __ ]
martial arts school all right I'd send
him there a little dog cage and I will
give
[ __ ] how much he cried and even though
it break my heart watching his glasses
fog up it's like dude you know this is
gonna happen you every [ __ ] day I'm
doing you a favor alright you're gonna
be the one scientist in the world that
knows how to fight okay and then
meanwhile I would go out I go to a load
of local sporting goods store and I'd
buy a BB gun and I would drive over to
the kids house that beat up my kid and
I'd shoot his dad in the neck from
across the street I might shoot at all
of them might go up on a tree and just
keep him pinned down for a while
although I don't know if he could do
that now now at the age of cell phones
is around that's another reason why cell
phones suck it's all so hard it's so
hard to have a conversation with
something now cuz they're always looking
at the text messages and [ __ ] right but
now not only that because of cell phones
you've completely eliminated all
possibilities unless you just don't care
about getting caught of pinning down
another family with a BB gun from a tree
across the street you know I'm telling
you people how many more freedoms are we
gonna lose in this country before
somebody steps up and does something you
know it's funny I'm laying on the floor
right now and I have my head up against
the wall and my bald spot in the back of
my head is making my head really cold
Oh aging isn't it fun
so anyways listen to this [ __ ] week
listen let's just go over my [ __ ]
last couple of weeks this is how [ __ ]
insane my life has been alright I went
to London did a show there Copenhagen
Oslo Helsinki Stockholm Sweden I fly
home we stopped in Zurich Switzerland so
I get to look at the Swiss Alps granted
out of my little [ __ ] porthole of a
window actually I was sitting in the
middle of the plane it was one giant
planes where they have like three three
sections I was in the aisle in the
middle and this [ __ ] goddamn
I wouldn't get a big [ __ ] head out of
the way but I still saw him flew home
then oh my god I'm gonna rest up for a
couple with like a week here before I go
back to New York or do the whole
Carnegie thing and then what happens out
of the blue I get a call somebody
dropped out I got to do panel for the
first time on the Jimmy Fallon show by
the way thank you to everybody on the
Jimmy Fallon show and if there's any
music geeks out there I forget the name
of it the song that they played the
roots played when I came out I had
actually heard of it before and forgot
about it was actually a song Bill Cosby
wrote like some sort of I don't know he
what you know he's into jazz I don't
know I never really watched that show
but I wanted I wanted to hear it because
I was so like when I walked out you know
the first time you do stand-up on a
late-night show it's like you dreamed it
because there's so much [ __ ] you're
taking in you're already dealing with oh
my god what if I bomb on national TV
then you walk out and then there's a
bunch of cameras there's the band
there's the host and then behind all of
this the cameras is this studio audience
and they're totally amped up and they
laugh and they clap in weird places I
don't know why but they do so you got to
do that so you got to do like two or
three of them before you start to get
used to that so I'm thinking all right
I'm doing panel this is gonna be this
will be easy
I don't have to [ __ ] I got another
person to bounce stuff off of the blah
blah blah but even that came out and it
took me a couple of minutes to get going
I thought or whatever it took me a
minute and I have to kind of feel it out
oh my god there's the band over there
there's Jimmy those are my shoes that's
the crowd how do I do this who do I look
at and I don't know then I kind of
figured it out about a minute and a half
in so anyway so I got to do that that
was a little sidetrack there so I get to
do that [ __ ] right do my little Midwest
tour come back oh wait and then I did
Opie and Anthony and it just so happens
when I do open Anthony I go in there two
days one day I go in there Tony Iommi
comes in from Black Sabbath
I got to ask him a couple questions
about John Bonham's bass drum technique
he didn't know but I still got to ask
him and then two days later Ace Frehley
came in from kiss got to shoot two [ __ ]
with him you know found out his last
name isn't freely it's Frehley and
that's why it was fray Lee's comment
like Halley's Comet Opie figured that
out never knew that [ __ ] fly back
[ __ ] home come back again and I get
to do Carnegie Hall
I do Carnegie Hall then I [ __ ] the
next day I go up to Boston perform at my
old college they give me some sort of
award for being comic of the six one
seven area code right but I'll take it
and then comics come home just happen to
be up the street they said hey somebody
dropped out why don't you come by so I
[ __ ] went up there and I did that oh
by the way Robert Kelly boy Bobby Kelly
Robert [ __ ] Kelly [ __ ]
destroyed on the comics come home
absolutely [ __ ] destroyed it was like
he wasn't even doing his act it was like
hanging out with Bobby in a [ __ ] what
I have a coffee shop or whatever he was
just he was [ __ ] it's a funniest I've
ever seen him I was dying laughs and
then I was like I'll [ __ ] I got to go on
after this so then it anyways then I'm
flying home okay and I'm thinking all
right the Patriots they're gonna lose to
the Jets they're gonna [ __ ] loose
this our defense is horrific our offense
our offensive line hasn't been able to
block anybody lately all these douche I
got a text some somebody here the
Steelers finally figured out Brady oh
did you figure out that if he's on his
back he can't throw a [ __ ] pass you
jackass did you figure out that if he
has a [ __ ] defense and if he's sitting
on the sidelines for 17 minutes with his
teeth chatter
because he hasn't thrown a ball in like
20 minutes that that's gonna [ __ ] with
his timing absolutely absolutely but I
get it I understand why you guys have
sent IIIC through all your emails I all
you're saying is I'm so psyched after a
decade of getting ass-raped by that
good-looking son of a [ __ ] with the
[ __ ] supermodel wife I'm so glad we
finally put him on his back I get it I
know what you guys are going through I
dealt with [ __ ] Dan Marino that
tanned up glove wearing son of a [ __ ]
used to come up every [ __ ] time kick
our ass and then you go down we go down
to the Orange Bowl and he'd be even more
tan looking like Tony Curtis back there
with his [ __ ] Dennis Miller mullet
and he'd be just killing us I know I
know what you're going through so I'm
sitting I'm getting on the flight like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I thought the Patriots
Jets game was a one o'clock game so I
got myself a five o'clock flight and I
ended up realizing as I went down there
that it was the eight o'clock game and I
had a six hour flight and basically I
was gonna land with like [ __ ] five
minutes to go so my god Jesus Christ you
know something they're gonna get their
asses kicked I just don't believe in
that defense I mean I think we can go up
against you know you know eight and
eight teams and below and put on a good
performance but I don't see us doing
well against the top teams and despite
the Jets record you know they still got
a great defense and they did go to the
AFC Championship two times in a row if
they [ __ ] Bend there that's why I
knew they were gonna kick the bills ass
last week they [ __ ] been that they've
got too much experience I was just like
ah [ __ ] or at least I don't have to sit
there in age twenty years watching this
game and I figured when I landed
everybody was gonna be sending me these
text messages saying that the the
[ __ ] Patriots got their asses kicked
and [ __ ] Tom Brady it's [ __ ] over two
New York teams in a row and when I
landed I'm not even gonna lie to you I
was absolutely stunned that they were
winning but the level that they are
winning so I am NOT going to talk [ __ ]
because as you heard on my podcast
last week I did not have any faith and I
thought that that we were gonna lose not
only lose to them I thought the Jets
were gonna win the division all right so
if I were to go on the podcast this week
and start talking [ __ ] you know what
that would make me that would make me
like a [ __ ] Yankees fan like all
those [ __ ] who I didn't hear from until
[ __ ] in you know since Game three of
2004 and then the Red Sox choked and
they all crawl out of their [ __ ]
holes and then the next week they lose
to the targets in the first round and
then they disappear again I don't want
to be that guy so I'm absolutely stunned
the level [ __ ] defense played
unbelievable all of a sudden we had a
pass for pass rush what happened there
that Jets have some sort of injury on
their offensive line I couldn't [ __ ]
believe it
so anyways um so I really have nothing
to complain about everything has just
totally worked
I'm almost like I've had such a great
month I'm afraid to walk out of my house
feeling as though a piano is gonna fall
on my head just to balance [ __ ] out so
which brings us to Carnegie Hall that I
sort of glanced over and I don't know
how to do this I guess it was some funny
[ __ ] happen but I I gotta tell you I
want to thank everybody from the bottom
of my heart first of all that ever came
to one of my comedy shows that sat there
while I sucked and tried to figure out
how to become a comedian all the way
back to 92 right up to everybody who
came out to Carnegie Hall last Friday
night it was without a doubt the
greatest thing experience I've ever had
as a since I've been in this business
there's no other way it's it was
absolutely indescribable it was it was I
can't even [ __ ] explain it I like I
told you guys a couple weeks ago I
stopped looking at the names of the
people who perform there because it was
freaking me out so this is a funny thing
I get virzi Mersey I got virzi to open
for me and I had the sensation in the
middle the teen idol sensation
Joe DeRosa from the Opie and Anthony
program just back from an extended tour
in Malibu he was resting up he was
suffering from exhaustion so anyway so I
go in and you know they got all these
rules there cuz this is like Carnegie
Hall that all these rules I had a
photographer there but the photographer
couldn't go on the stage and there was
just all these these [ __ ] rules so I
went in there like almost on my heels
like I don't want to piss anybody off in
here and I walked in there and they said
okay you're up in the maestro suite like
if you headline that place they put you
in the place called the maestro suite so
I go all the way up there I'm with
family and friends I go up there and I
feel like I'm gonna get in trouble like
I'm describing like the [ __ ] seventh
floor the Pentagon here so I walk in
there and this is piano piano in this
giant like this big room and then
there's another room with the classic
I'm in showbiz lights going all around
the mirror and then they have all these
composers headshots all around the the
maestro suite and they're all
autographed and immediately I felt like
I didn't deserve to be there cuz not
only were they these famous conductors I
didn't know who any of them were I was
sitting there looking at him like oh
yeah rubbin my chin Leonard Bernstein
was the only one I noticed the only one
that I recognized and we I just you know
just tried to [ __ ] take it in and
then they said hey you want to go
downstairs and look at the stage and I
said absolutely and I walked down took
us down the elevator and they opened the
door to go out to the stage and all you
see is the most well lit stage you've
ever seen he'll I'm just looking through
a door the average size door that you
open and I'm about 20 feet away they
when they opened it so I could see part
of the stage
like a sliver of the front row seats and
then like all like three balconies going
up and it was I mean I'm gonna lie it
was [ __ ] took my breath away and I
look I never said holy [ __ ] and I
immediately apologize for cursing
because that's how nice this place like
I wasn't gonna go out there and say [ __ ]
every other word when I do my horse [ __ ]
of an act and and I walked out there and
I it's indescribable
absolutely [ __ ] indescribable and I I
just I can't even why I'm bringing it up
I can't even describe it it was just it
was [ __ ] yeah there was no I I'd
never seen anything like it it was like
I was in Pulp Fiction I got to see what
was in that briefcase was like look it's
like at that level I I can't even put
words into it so so then I go back up to
the the maestro's suite that just like
saying that so I'm sitting up there and
I'm like hey is virzi and DeRosa here
yet they're like yeah they're downstairs
I go we'll get him up here get him up
here cuz I don't know [ __ ] guys be
sitting up here looking at these old
[ __ ] silver haired guys with
composers just look angry in their
pictures they just got that [ __ ] look
on their face like I don't know what
happened like they didn't really want to
be a composer but their parents made him
do it
it was just creeping me out they got all
these [ __ ] pictures every God every
anybody post Abraham Lincoln has
basically been there I saw a picture of
Mark Twain sitting down on the stage
listening to somebody else speak Teddy
Roosevelt Benny Goodman Duke Ellington
Miles Davis all the way through all
those jazz guys to the [ __ ] Beatles
Stevie Ray Vaughan made an album that
was overwhelming so I get I go I don't
even feel like I'm worried to be here
what is gonna cure this I know
get Paul virzi and Joe DeRosa in the
same room with me and I'll get my
confidence back so these two jackasses
come up there all right
DeRosa is sweating and muttering to
himself virzi is [ __ ] pacing all
right I'm pacing all three of us are
pacing around this room as we're talking
isn't it amazing to be here we're all
[ __ ] pacing and then we just started
breaking each other's balls about how
nervous we were and then we just started
trying to make each other even more
nervous like I noticed they were nervous
that I came I came walking and I was
like you know guys if you're ever gonna
[ __ ] bomb tonight better not be the
night cuz you're not getting this one
back this is not the [ __ ] night to
bomb and everybody laughed and then
there was that nervous thing Versys
going like hey you know uh you know I go
out there you know I'm gonna do I'm just
gonna you know I'm just gonna treat it
like Caroline's gonna say what's up to
people you know I'm gonna settle in
first I'm was selling first then I'm
gonna go into my act yeah that's what
I'm gonna do so just to be a douche I go
really that's what you're gonna die you
know I mean this is what you want to do
that's cool I mean I wouldn't do that
you think we do it I would go right in
my act
it's Carnegie Hall man you don't go out
there and hey what's going on you're
gonna start [ __ ] bombing but you know
but I want to get in your head do it if
that's what you want to do and he's
sitting there trying to size me up for
half a second you know he's just like
you know it's like I go [ __ ] yourself we
basically did that for a goddamn 45
minutes waiting to go on I was as
nervous as I was the first time I I did
Letterman which was one of the most
butterflies I ever had that that nervous
yet excited wanting to run out of the
room yet can't waiting to go on like
that whole [ __ ] push-pull [ __ ] going
on you know so anyways the show starts
virzi goes out there and absolutely
[ __ ] kills and then he bring in and
it's [ __ ] hilarious he comes walking
out dude with this this [ __ ] look on
his face you know like the only thing
stopped his [ __ ] lips from going
around the back of his head was his
goddamn ears like just like glowing like
you like see I can't explain it we all
look like [ __ ]
DeRosa came off Jarosz it goes on he
goes out there and immediately starts
[ __ ] oh you know what really made me
relax virzi went up and he goes he said
something a go give yourselves a round
of applause huh bill burr tonight
at Carnegie [ __ ] Hall the second he
did that I laughed and I was like I
[ __ ] know it's just a stand-up show
but uh - Rosa goes out there next and
with his stupid sport coat on and
everything you know which was making him
sweat even more and he went out there
and [ __ ] absolutely destroyed he
comes back same stupid [ __ ] look on
his face and actually Miami one time I
read about these divers who used to go
into caves under the sea and when they
get lost and they would drown under
there and when they would find him
they'd have this ear to ear grin I guess
when you drown at the last second this
unbelievable level of dopamine or some
[ __ ] goes through you just stupid look
on your face I don't know if that's true
I don't know where the [ __ ] I read it
like I read it on flight on us so that
was basically you know when the article
made me laugh as horrific as it was
imagining somebody drowning in an
underwater cave freaking out not knowing
where they're at but just that dumb
smile in their face it sort of was like
the look people had on their face was
was the reverse of that movie the ring
rather than your jaw dropping over and
was horrific just imagine the other
polar opposite of smiling that was
basically so DeRosa comes walking
through and he's got this [ __ ] silly
stupid look on his face mercy said he's
just gonna bring me right up so I'm
standing there waiting to go on and
standing a few feet behind me was Luis
Fernanda from Caroline's and those guys
were the ones who headlined me when I
first came you know and I first started
doing well in New York they would
headline me and they had to pull the
curtain you know to make not make the
room look so big and only you know 14
people would show up and then they'd
drag like another 20 people tourists off
the street to come in and watch my show
so he was standing there going like oh I
was going Louis go out in the crowd he
goes no no I want to stand here and
watch you go out I want to watch you go
which was [ __ ] awesome you don't
Caroline's one of the biggest clubs ever
so they [ __ ] open the door call my
name and I walk out and
I'm not trying to be arrogant here they
were just great fans everybody [ __ ]
stood up as I walked out like I composed
some unbelievable song and it was
[ __ ] how I didn't just say I know I
had that big dumb grin on my face but
how I didn't just you know as I was
waving how I didn't just keep just get
locked in that mode and just walked
right off the end of the [ __ ] stage
is beyond me come and I went in and I I
can't even where I started with I don't
remember what I started with and I just
did my [ __ ] and it slowly became like a
show just a regular show where every
once in a while I would just sort of go
and [ __ ] I'm at Carnegie Hall and then
I'd be like no no no keep going keep
going just keep going because that was a
thing every kept going you know make
sure you take it in make sure you take
it in you know and that's the fucked-up
thing about the art of stand-up this is
like the one art where you really can't
take it in
you can't cuz you got to be focused on
what you're doing you know what I mean
like it's a musician you can end the
[ __ ] song you can step back you can
tell the story you can look around and
then you can go into your next song but
that's a Sisk bam bam bam next joke next
joke next joke so I I don't know I did
my [ __ ] and it it just took off at like
minute three and it didn't stop for like
and I think I did about an hour and 15
minutes and I never lost him it never
felt long and I ended and it was a
standing ovation again and it just was
one of the few times in my life I just
felt like this unbelievable sense of
accomplishment and it was I don't and
was also absolutely hilarious to me like
it I didn't feel like I should I felt
like at any second someone was gonna
yank me like it was a joke like I won a
radio contest
out there and then they were gonna yank
me off and bring like [ __ ] some
Pavarotti dude out there so that was
awesome and then the end I brought virzi
and DeRosa back out and everyone's
standing up clapping and we just sitting
there [ __ ] it we just it was hell it
was it was
I came describe it it was awesome and it
was it was [ __ ] hilarious ridiculous
and I had this great photographer there
and he actually took photos of me and
Joe as we were walking down the street
afterwards and I saw some of them it's
it's [ __ ] hilarious
the the absolute look of joy on our
faith two miserable comedians like I
swear to god we look like we are high on
like I don't know what I'm not a big
[ __ ] drug guy whatever high on
something but it was absolutely [ __ ]
unbelievable and I'll never forget it I
will never forget it so I want to thank
everybody who came out to the show and
experienced it with me and [ __ ] stood
up and clapped which was [ __ ]
unbeliever forget that ever I'll be
[ __ ] a hundred years old and I will
still remember that like it like it was
yesterday was absolutely unbelievable
still one of the few things in my life
that is not only lived up to the hype it
was it was like way beyond it like it
just [ __ ] indescribable then
describable you know I don't know what I
have no [ __ ] clue I don't know I
don't know where to go from here so
there's the Carnegie Hall story alright
so once again thank you everybody who
came out to that show oh and if you're
wondering did I record that yes I did
of course I did what do you think I'm an
[ __ ] I'm gonna go there I'm not gonna
record it I don't know what I'm gonna do
with it yet because I didn't film it
because it was it was just it's Carnegie
Hall and it would have cost me my life
my firstborn to film something there so
but to record it the audio version was
only half as much
I'm not even bullshitting you I think I
lost money that night but I don't give a
[ __ ] I want it I want it documented that
this jackass who flunked everything in
high school somehow got the [ __ ] and do
that so so this is the thing the my next
stand-up special I'm going to be
recording in in February the end of the
first weekend of March is what I'm gonna
be doing alright so here's the deal my
act is constantly evolving so my act
will be one two three four month really
December yeah four months older than it
is now so it will change 120 days worth
so it won't be the exact the Carnegie
thing and my special will not be the
exact same but so much of it will be the
same that I'm gonna figure out you know
obviously I'm putting the DVD out I have
to figure out how I'm gonna put out the
Carnegie thing and when how I'm gonna do
it so it's a way where I don't feel like
I'm [ __ ] you guys over where I'm
putting out two pieces of product with
essentially the same material I actually
already know how I'm gonna do it but
yeah I'm not gonna tell you guys until I
[ __ ] do it but it's gonna be cool as
hell alright so there you go so let's
get back to the podcast after that very
special moment come on Carnegie Hall I
had to take a step back and I got to
tell you it was [ __ ] awesome to to
share that with virzi and DeRosa and
seeing those [ __ ] stupid goofy looks
on their face watching them pace and be
nervous and watching them [ __ ] go out
there and they had all their family and
friends and that's it was [ __ ] it was
awesome it was awesome alright let's get
back to the goddamn podcast so as I
mentioned I have a brand new website
everybody for some reason I can't get on
it right now I don't know if they did
putting the final touches on it I don't
know if it's because it moved somewhere
else I don't know if it's cuz they I
don't know
what you know me I'm not good with the
technology but here's the deal
it's a [ __ ] awesome site it's gonna
be very interactive I'm gonna get the
new [ __ ] iPhone when I don't have to
stand in line or [ __ ] order it I just
want to walk in and buy it like a
goddamn gentleman all right what is this
Russia
go [ __ ] yourself I walk in it's supposed
to be there call me why don't you call
me when it's there all right battery's
crapped out on me sorry about that what
was I talking about yeah this isn't
[ __ ] Russia all right this isn't some
country that I've heard you have to
stand in line in you know I just want to
walk in and get it I'm sorry can we
don't hand him if you like the ordinary
we can play singing Oh [ __ ] order it
yourself I don't give a [ __ ]
I actually like getting it later cousin
up there's a problem either people
figure it out with their wallets
you know all these people like when
people get like new technology like that
and you can tell that they're just using
it in front of you just to try and show
off like you actually give a [ __ ] so
anyways my new website you know if you
you know send me Twitter's or Facebook's
all that shit's gonna be right there on
the page just go to Bill burr comm I'm
sure it's up by the time you listen to
this it's up there I got some fancy new
photos up there I got a new bio I'm
gonna start blogging again my all my
podcasts are gonna be there be there so
you can listen to it it's gonna be great
and this is the new me I'm finally going
to embrace this [ __ ] technology [ __ ]
but I'm doing it my way
all right speaking of that I am in my
croissant what am i Mac I mean though I
have a Word document right now and I
don't know what the [ __ ] I did but I hit
something and they got these little blue
things after every line that I write you
know like I got all this [ __ ] that I
want to talk about like Carnegie I just
make like a set list just [ __ ] Carnegie
what do I got else up here rope climbing
these [ __ ] blue things oh here we go
yeah
these [ __ ] blue things I don't know
what it is I write a sentence and at the
end of the sentence says these little
blue things
marking something I want them gone I
don't know how to get rid of them how do
I get rid of him come on you techie son
of a [ __ ] help me out here
what else today o nene leakes you guys
watch The Real Housewives of Atlanta
baby my girl watches that show and
there's a girl on there this girl nene
leakes she's [ __ ] hilarious and could
probably beat the [ __ ] out of me and two
of my friends at the same time she said
some [ __ ] that just [ __ ] made me
laugh my ass off this week she went down
there right because I guess now she's a
reality star and judging by the way
she's talking about her finances this
girl would like up before the show if
you gave her a George Foreman grill for
her birthday she would probably faint
because she went in and bought her son a
car a used car spent $13,000 on it wrote
a check and then she started bragging
about it on TV talking about how she was
rich she goes just bought my just bought
my baby a $13,000 card she goes cash
money and she goes hey haters and she
starts blowing kisses at him talking
talking about how she's rich it was
[ __ ] hilarious you know I don't know
a lot about rich people but I know
there's two things they don't do number
one they don't use the expression Cash
Money and number two even if they did
they don't they don't [ __ ] buy
$13,000 used cars all right
Cash Money is one of them [ __ ] is one
of those things that lets people know
that you have been rich for ten minutes
whether they call they call that new
money not saying that I'm [ __ ] up
across they'd see it through me just by
the way I talk the way I say I'm going
doing I don't pronounce my jeez I don't
know I you know I never took a fencing
class right when I go to bang one of
their rich daughters and go to dance
with her I don't have a handkerchief but
to put between my hand in her hand I
don't know how to do that so I they
would
see through me but uh cash money that
just means you what you will [ __ ]
broke oh my god what's that well you
know what you know what's the dumbest
thing you could do with your cash money
is to go out and buy a $13,000 used car
with it Cash Money drove it off the lot
now it's worth nine thousand cash money
I just lost three thousand Cash Money
hey haters hey you know it's one of my
favorite dumb jokes of the year that I
heard if you guys heard that one yet
what is a gay horse eat hey it always
makes me laugh I don't know why it just
[ __ ] makes me laugh anyways let's get
to the the question but you got to watch
that girl nene leakes because there's
nothing funnier than watching a girl get
punched in the head by another girl
because it's it's brutal when a guy does
it when a girl does it all of a sudden
some fair fight and you get to kind of
see what in the back of your psycho head
you really want to see you know it's
nene leakes is doing what is a man you
would love to do to some loud-mouthed
[ __ ] [ __ ] who won't shut her goddamn
Yap you know but you just got to sit
there and take it cuz she's got a
vajayjay right nene leakes is a super
hero for me i put on i will watch that
show I will sit through the dumb fight
and I just hope with every episode
that's what I have Nia do I just have
her you know I kind of listen and I walk
in on and out of the room and I just
wait for her to slap the [ __ ] out of
somebody is my fate um she grabs their
hair and they don't know how to fight
it's just the funniest [ __ ] thing she
knows how to fight though like I said
she could kick my ass in her big [ __ ]
ghetto heels and there isn't a god and
she would talk to me as she did it like
Ali and it wouldn't be a [ __ ] thing I
could do about it but that [ __ ] was
hilarious just bought a car
Cash Money
[ __ ] use [ __ ] hey this nobody's hate
nobody alright
did I just say nobody's hating I feel
like a douche alright let's get to the
[ __ ] advice and all that [ __ ]
this week what do we got what do we get
honey what am I am 50 minutes into this
thing all right only I would follow up a
heartfelt story about playing Carnegie
Hall with talking about some reality
show star slapping the [ __ ] out of some
woman's all right let's let's do some
dilemmas for the week all right all
right these these are actually getting
more and more evolved a lot of them were
sexual or just disgusting
very sophomoric so please try to expand
these things because like I said all of
yours initially were all incestuous that
I wasn't gonna do those and then it just
became gross out stuff and sex [ __ ]
which is still good at this point I have
no problem but like I want something a
couple ones like this one this is a
great one is a dilemma would you rather
give up football or socks ah dude that
is that is the hardest dilemma that I've
been presented with I hate wearing shoes
or sneakers without socks I hate when
you feet get hot and they start sticking
to the goddamn soul and every time you
take a step party a foot comes up and
then it just slaps back down again you
[ __ ] goddamn shoes start stinking so
that's basically would you rather give
up quality of life or the sport you love
and that would mean I couldn't go to
football games in November or December
I'm not wearing any socks I I think I
might have to flip a coin on this one I
think I'd have to I'd have to give up
would I give up football because I could
watch all the other sports oh but that's
the [ __ ] manliest of them all other
than hockey oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know what do I got a coin I'm gonna
go to the [ __ ] coin right now I'm
gonna flip the coin how about I flip my
cellphone because I should I'm getting
rid of this in two weeks
all right screen side up I give up sucks
backside up I give up football and there
we go screen side up I give up socks oh
god that would suck could I at least
wear a leg warmers oh Jesus that's
[ __ ] brutal a no sock wearing
football watching jackass that's what I
would be and I'd have stinky shoes and
that would affect the level of [ __ ] I
got or at the very least if I'm in a
[ __ ] relationship it would really
make her consider cheating on me or just
breaking up with me okay how much money
you make if you have stinky shoes that's
you know a woman's only gonna put up
with that for so long
uh-huh be that guy in a flight who
couldn't take off his [ __ ] shoes all
right you son of a [ __ ] that was a good
one all right would you rather be caught
cheating or catch your significant other
cheating I'd rather be go depends on
what kind of a relationship I'm in if I
want to get out of it I'd rather catch
them cheating if I love the person Oh
God
would you rather break her heart or have
your heart broken you [ __ ] are
good this week um I got to go selfish
I'm going selfish [ __ ] that I would
never be able to get over it a woman can
get over it
a guy can not saying all women we can't
get over that I can't get over the fact
that somebody entered your [ __ ] body
what did I do
I just stuck my dick in somebody like
[ __ ] ray lit the grass you I did I
[ __ ] I apologize for that hacky
impression um yeah I'd much rather be
caught cheating
I think it's more socially acceptable
than I've cheated I think that it's more
socially acceptable that the woman
forgives you I just don't think I just
don't think it's it's hey Nia what's
going on come on in lay down here next
to the wall here's one for you you came
in right during a nice dilemma I don't
have another microphone for you here oh
gee eh so here's one for is a dilemma
for you would you rather be caught
cheating or catch your significant other
cheating well I see yeah that's a good
one I said I went selfish I'd rather be
caught cheating because I couldn't have
a handle the fact that someone else you
know stuck did ding-a-ling and yeah I
would rather catch you cheating
you'd rather catch me cheating angel why
cuz you know what the guilt did you know
what that I'd [ __ ] dumped your ass
what why when I just asked why why would
I rather yeah I would rather be in that
situation than be caught cheating
because you're an angel you'd rather you
don't want to be a piece of [ __ ] exactly
you're just a better human being than I
am I mean I thought you were like I know
you're giving me the green light I
thought I saw you waving me around third
base all right you know what every
couple of years but you know what you
could be in the other room and if it
sounded like we were going too far
you'll be like eh eh eh none of that
none of that all right here we go
all right yeah I just saw a good one all
right here's one for you would you
rather be fluent in all languages or
master every musical instrument Oh would
you rather be able to talk to the world
yeah I think fluent fluent in all
languages yeah yeah yeah definitely
definitely I I'm going selfish again
yeah I'd rather I'd be a master of every
musical instrument and then I would I
would communicate through my instruments
and I would get Bangladesh [ __ ] if you
can play
the guitar [ __ ] that yeah you can get
you can get laid all over the world if
you can play a guitar then if even if
you're singing even if you're singing a
language in a singing in a different
language like right now as much as you
love me if some French guy was out there
with the guitar and he was going frère
Jacques Frere Jacques dormez-vous you
would be [ __ ] looking out the window
I would harsh Arc and then I'd be like
yes you would bow sure and we just
exposed ourselves from being surrounded
by water over here in the Americas we
don't nobody unless you sang it we don't
know it all right let's do one more
dilemma all right bill if your pasty ass
ever got sent to prison would you wait
to get shanked or just hang yourself and
yourself you know what I love I love
that they didn't even entertain the fact
that I could somehow survive in there
like you know really mess them up in
front of everybody
thus gaining the respect I think you'd
obviously make everyone laugh I wouldn't
be afraid of the the Aryan Nation
wanting to recruit you all right hang on
a second first of all you obviously
haven't watched any of those national
Geographics behind prison walls I'll
tell you this if I went if I went to
white-collar prison where you get to
play ping pong with Bernie Madoff I
think I could actually survive in that
one but I'll tell you know I actually
every guy that's the biggest was what is
the biggest [ __ ] fear going to jail
and becoming somebody's [ __ ] right that
like if they have it if they oh look at
you look at you you think you got me
[ __ ] wrapped around your finger see
that see what they do when you finally
tell them that you love them then they
throw it your [ __ ] face what is what
is wrong with you you were so cute five
seconds ago now I just I want to mush
your face into the
anyways okay if I was in a white-collar
prison I could survive that but okay
it's the biggest fear every got like if
they ever did the Family Feud what is
the biggest fear guy has and they and
the guy goes getting raped and being
somebody's prison [ __ ] Dayna be number
one answer you want to play you want to
pass let's play [ __ ] and then we
uh coming home and seeing my wife
sucking my best friend's dick okay good
answer good answer coming home seeing
your wife sucking your best friend's
dick bag number two and then you always
have the one weirdo and your family okay
what is the number one fear little man
can have in life okay I'm gonna say I
used all the good ones having somebody
borrow a tool and not put it back where
it belongs and then we'd have to sit
they'd be like you know a dumb [ __ ]
alright not being able to get it up okay
getting raped in prison being that
person having it yeah having to tie off
your shirt at the waist and be like hi
the brute is being that guy not being
able to get it up not being able to
provide for your family what else well
let's just do me women not [ __ ] you
yeah you
marriage failing then there's overlap
ones that you guys fear I don't know
let's not turn this into some psychology
thing I don't need to do this I'm trying
to be funny here alright I don't let's
let's get back to this thing you know
what's something there's a question for
you guys this week give me give me your
let's do the family [ __ ] feud top ten
your top ten fears I want to hear them
and then maybe we'll do like a little
survey
and then I'll get sued by that show and
then they'll realize I'm not making any
money on the podcast all right bill if
you pasty-ass ever got sent to prison
would you wait to get shanked or just
hang yourself in your cell I couldn't
hang my I couldn't kill myself I don't
know what I would do I would probably I
don't know what I would do I would I
would you know something I I would join
the Aryan Nation that's what I would do
I'd have to I'd have to [ __ ] I got to
do something I would call I would take I
take I take a [ __ ] in the cafeteria I
take one of the plastic forks and I
carve a swastika right between my eyes
just like like Charles Manson shaved my
head I don't know and I would I would
[ __ ] I would just walk up Sieg Heil
into all those [ __ ] dudes and just
try to be like yeah these [ __ ] Jews
[Laughter]
those goddamn Porto Ricans over there
other than Mexicans whatever okay I
would I would go I would say over the
top racist [ __ ] and that that's what I
would do yeah but I'm already gonna get
the [ __ ] kicked out of me come on Nene
come on I'm in good shape I'm exotic
with my red hair I'd be a little
blue-eyed [ __ ] in there I'd have to do
I am no I am no exotic out here that's
[ __ ] hilarious out here I am but in
prison and present prison I immediately
become like some Brazilian [ __ ]
walking down right head guys I have
watched those set over here near the mic
I have watched those thing
repeatedly those prison things I have
never seen anybody who looks like me
occasionally I saw one redheaded dude he
was a little [ __ ] you know
twelve-year-old kid he killed another
like [ __ ] for your date there was
almost too young to kill things I
watched and he had really weird ears he
did he looked like that somebody boxed
is here like like he looked like the
Hulk boxed his ears but they didn't
become cauliflower they just got dented
on the identity r--'s so long story
short he was a little redhead and so he
went in there he [ __ ] killed this kid
and it was so horrific they sent him to
a real person prison and and and he yeah
big boy not the daycare and he [ __ ]
he shaved his head he she got to you
can't walk around look it's Audi duty
time who's gonna [ __ ] me in the ass is
it your turn or his there's nothing I
can do I'm gonna be a racist you know
they just get yeah I would just have to
do I got to fall in with somebody you
know I can't pull off the I'm down
homeboys [ __ ]
you know I don't think I do very well I
don't think they appreciate you know
snappy clever nerd like behavior now you
wouldn't last a day you would be staring
at a [ __ ] and about [ __ ] eight
minutes some real manly looking chick
who's running [ __ ] and then her and then
her bottom [ __ ] would get jealous so
after you're done doing that smash your
[ __ ] face on pretty girl yeah but
you're you're a [ __ ] psycho though
you're a [ __ ] psycho you throw a good
punch you just have to commit to it your
problem is just like me you've never
crossed that [ __ ] line you you just
you just never did you know you just
never did so you're so not [ __ ]
prepared and not to mention I had
somebody one time we watched in the UFC
I've told this before in the podcast we
were watching the UFC and it's just one
of those guys saint-pierre one of these
games you
just physical specimen standing up
throwing hands kick in on the ground
choke yo just no matter where you went
as long as you have a [ __ ] weapon
this guy would [ __ ] you up knees elbows
right god damn anything you can throw it
you'd [ __ ] you up and I was joking go
look at these these guys on rape Abul
[ __ ] that like they got to that level
yeah that's the highest level belt you
can get in martial arts is [ __ ]
unreal
and I was talking to this dude he's like
nah they'd still get a guy like that I
go how he goes yeah you know they gang
up on you
they put [ __ ] in your food they drugged
your food if they really want to get you
they'll drug and I drug your food and I
can't even tell you how deflated of a
feeling I felt when they told me that
even the champions of the UFC if they
wanted to they could get to them that's
how [ __ ] hardcore prisoners so what
would I I don't know what I would do
crazy yeah but you know what I would do
I would attack a guard because I would
attack a guard there you go because
they're not gonna they're not gonna rape
me they're just gonna beat me up I'll
take the beatdown
but then even then if I attack the guard
for half a second they be like oh look
at this crazy son of a [ __ ] but then
when I started making those little girl
noises when I took my first Rodney King
beating when I was doing that I'd get at
my ass kicked and then I'd get raped
when I came out no one is unbel you know
something I think we might end the
podcast on that I think I think we
learned something today in this crazy
world we live in people you have to tell
people you love them you have to enjoy
every day because nobody is unreachable
it's one of this harshest truths that's
that's what ends your childhood the day
you realize that this is really that you
know something that's so [ __ ] true
it's not even funny let's let me get
into something happier than that I
actually I told this really nice story
about doing Carnegie Hall and how
awesome was it it was amazing you got a
standing ovation when you came out as
well as I told him it was [ __ ]
unbelievable greatest greatest I I can't
even talk about all right overrated bad
overrated relationships do I really want
to read this one with you he's here
can you come near the microphone abhi a
frigging professional in this
unprofessional show why are you wearing
moccasins they're moccasins what do you
get nothing I get nothing on that that
was stupid
you know what what go [ __ ] yourself here
we go relationships so sure they can be
good but are they ever great every
married guy I know reminisce about his
days as a single man married guys worn
single guys not to get into
relationships they warned guys with
girlfriends to never under any
circumstances get married this is all
true when you're single you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want whatever you
want without first I get this closer
without first filtering your decisions
through the desires of a chick who
probably doesn't even know what she
wants most of the time and is motivated
by the worldview of Sex in the City
sounds like a real prize no but this is
true though this isn't all women a lot
of women of [ __ ] idiots just like
guys when you say most guys are [ __ ]
idiots
I would actually and aren't most women
aren't most people [ __ ] idiots listen
we're all rape Abul but when we talk
all I know is that no one is unreadable
okay okay and I am as exotic as a
grilled cheese sandwich I think that
might be an instant classic there wasn't
even tomato in that sandwich was there
even when the chicks get what they think
they want they you they're usually still
miserable that's how stupid most of them
are all right now yeah now he's thanks
Keith this is in my school he's in my
quad I like this guy you're never gonna
make them happy so why even try not
being constrained by a relationship is
one of the greatest things of all time
it's a man's world women need more women
need men more than men need women most
men can thrive alone most women can't
he's young you can tell he's young he
hasn't he hasn't like women are still
looking at him and he's learning I was
this guy then you realize at some point
you're old and women don't care anymore
so you got to grab one and just hang on
to him drag him down with you most women
can't ask any honest bisexual girl and
she'll like you tell you that she wants
to end up with a man Jesus this guy just
keeps every time I think he's gone as
far as he's gonna go he keeps going I
love him enjoy being single unless
you're a total [ __ ] failure of a man
you'll almost always be able to get a
girlfriend if you really want one
realize yeah if you're sick past a
certain age dude you there's a certain
amount of money you have to be making
before that to continue to happen and
this is there's a [ __ ] sadness to
that life that I can't even begin to
describe realize what a blessing your
freedom is and never allowed desperation
to put you in Chains he's making some
good points here he definitely has some
issues with women he's buddies there's a
lot of truth in that Nia they're all
enjoy dying alone [ __ ] hey hey hey
listen what this is well basically what
you just said was that you're a dumb
girl because that's what he was
attacking is your work it's your world
we were almost out without an argument
but why am i dumb because he's attacking
women whose worldview comes from Sex in
the City okay so somehow you got
offended by that first of all he's not
just attacking women who
worldview is sexy he's oh I think he is
he's attacking all women look oh I know
he was just some women he was just being
silly
he's just being silly oh you're right
you're right look you know his mother
never hugged him he's got issues he's
what don't drag me into this I relate to
this guy why don't you just speak for
yourself you [ __ ] delusional jackass
who elected you you did you know I
didn't say to represent all women's I'm
not representing all women's but I think
I can say with with with underwear is
clarity that most smart women who see
this would be like go [ __ ] yourself you
douche all right well can I just make a
comment about the whole marriage versus
unmarried thing the grass is always
greener on the other side single people
who are alone look at couples and I they
get a little twinge of like oh that's
nice I wish I had somebody to come home
to at night that has my back no matter
what that's what you're missing you
short-sighted [ __ ] is that you've got
somebody a hey there with you who's
gonna take this review who's gonna love
you and and protect you and have your
back it's not just about like being with
someone just to be with someone we got
it
listen how you cuz you're being mean
this podcast this podcast
this guy's crying out for help this
podcast is not about being mean and
taking shots at people who can't defend
themselves take you long enough to
figure that out all right no but this
this there's a great truth in what he's
saying here is a lot of people just jump
in relationship jump in relationship
jump in relationship and it's like
relationships are [ __ ] difficult yeah
okay so you better pick the right person
or you're gonna be [ __ ] miserable so
you are better off to be single and
lonely rather than just being in some
[ __ ] to just being some [ __ ] so you got
somebody to [ __ ] make brownies with
that's what he was trying to say all
right
say that he ended up saying that most
chicks are gonna be miserable anyway and
they all have the stupid worldview
that's true
most women are gonna be miserable and
they're never gonna be [ __ ] happy okay
you know something you guys always say a
good man is hard to find that works both
[ __ ] ways well then that's this is
what both wealth this [ __ ]
hasn't found the one yet so he's going
he's going he's dating about how to make
a relationship work and he can't find
the value in the relationship so
automatically it's not valuable first of
all the own person lashing out is you
right now you've lost your temper is a
guy here he writes in he's looking for a
little bit of goddamn guidance he wants
some advice
he got it he's [ __ ] hilarious all
right let's wrap this up here all right
Oh bad by the way YouTube video of the
week I actually forgot to send this to
my guy speaking of a man's world I just
remembered that if you want to see one
of the greatest [ __ ] gogosi would you
please talk into the mic oh yeah oh yeah
man that's somebody yellow oh Jesus I
wanted to do that I wanted to do the
yeah I want I wanted to do the yellow
cover instead of going oh yeah it's
gonna go oh gee well we'd have to pay
for the rights of it yes somebody
somebody somebody do that alright I'm
gonna give you a clean version of oh
Jesus that you can then [ __ ] with in
your own audio way all right
oh gee do you need a longer one for that
one part where he goes oh I'll give you
a longer one oh yay this podcast is
going off the rails
alright under a tiny one take underrated
showing off what's the under this guy's
the same guy underaged showing off
what's the best that can happen you blow
people's [ __ ] minds look like a God
among mortals and alpha and an alpha
[ __ ] male what's the big fear totally
[ __ ] up
why that can still be awesome still be
awesome look at Evel Knievel one of the
greatest show-offs of all time he [ __ ]
up big several times if you total if you
totally [ __ ] up while trying to show off
at least you give people a hilarious
story of how you failed while trying to
be a badass the worst thing that that
you can do is only succeed a little bit
if you're gonna show off either nail it
or [ __ ] it up completely they can be no
middle ground you either need to blow
people's [ __ ] minds or you need to
get them a hilarious failure anecdote
either way act like a man if you nail it
look smug and cocky as [ __ ] like the
superior human that you are if you fail
big laugh your ass off and still act
cocky at least you tried most of them
are too cowardly to even try it yeah see
this guy I'm tell you right now this guy
could chat you up in a bar in a [ __ ]
second nope same guy no nose because you
know all that other stuff yeah good yeah
I could yeah I could not [ __ ] now
I'm saying that um I'm not even gonna
get into it alright overrated Andrew
Luck no because I would [ __ ] it I
just it's not worth it everyone's you
know it's not worth its fourth and - I
know I could get it I'm up by 37 I don't
give a [ __ ]
oh the YouTube video of the week this is
the last thing I want to end right with
right now YouTube video of the week
James Brown singing it's a man's world
with Pavarotti one of the most gangster
things you're ever gonna [ __ ] watch
and I never used the word gangster but
it's totally totally necessary in it it
marries it was [ __ ] on it basically
marries although all of the cool [ __ ]
black Street [ __ ] with all the Italian
mob movies just it's the greatest mashup
ever and it's not a mash-up these guys
are old-school rather than having some
guy do it on a [ __ ] laptop they went
out and did the [ __ ] themselves and you
see you see James Brown at one point
after he sings all that [ __ ] about it
being being a man's world and then
Pavarotti starts singing that
/ all over the top of it at one point
even James Brown just shakes his head
like this is the [ __ ] [ __ ] you get James
Brown to do that forget it it's the
greatest thing ever so check that out
that's it for this week that's the
podcast once again from the bottom of my
heart thank you to anybody who ever came
out to my show the entire time my
phone's ringing the entire time that
I've ever done stand-up that helped lead
up to that night at Carnegie and thank
you to everybody who came out to the
show and and everybody who works with me
it [ __ ] fights it out with the
promoters and all that type of [ __ ]
thank you so much from the bottom I
heart I will never forget it best
[ __ ] week that's it that's the
podcast go [ __ ] yourselves I'll talk to
you next week
you